i'm going to introduce a bit more
language here like we talked about
modulus
and argument one of the things that we
need is the terminology to be able to
stop saying like long phrases i'm just
going to
think about them specifically right so
we've talked about the normal form of a
complex number starting with this
x plus i y business okay now this form
i've resisted naming it until now
because this is the only way that you
talked about complex numbers
but now that we have this other way of
representing them
i'm going to give you some names i'm
going to give you three okay
firstly because this is kind of where we
start it's the most common way that you
will see complex numbers represented
it is sometimes called the standard form
so this is just the regular one
that we see right however as you've been
seeing here we connected to the complex
plane
which looks so much like the cartesian
plane that's why we call these x and y
frequently so you also see this name and
this is the name that the syllabus
prefers you also see it called cartesian
form so when they say hey provide me a
complex number
and write it in cartesian form this is
what they mean
uh there is one other name it's the name
i uh sort of grew up with and it's sort
of my preferred name but
the most important thing about it is
that you recognize it whether you prefer
it or not
it's also sometimes called rectangular
form
and the reason for this comes again from
looking at the complex plane if you draw
up
you know any complex plane i chose all
my bad markers today no it happened
that one's okay if you think about the x
and the y where they sit on here right
we drew a
triangle in here with x and y but you
could also draw
a rectangle with x and y can you see
where it might go
um this one here which we drew before
there's your y if you place your x
up here then with the origin you form
this rectangle
okay so you're going to see x plus iy
referred to in all of these different
ways you need to be able to recognize
them
and this other form i am going to change
markers because that's going to bother
me
i'm going to go with that one should do
so we've written it as r out the front
and then you've got cos theta plus i
sine theta okay so how do we describe
this well what did we what name did we
give to r that distance
we call it the it comes from the radius
of a circle but we called it in this
context
the modulus right so you might call here
this called modulus
and then the theta is the argument so
you might hear this called
modulus argument form
but we usually try and save time when we
have names for things like this so
you might hear that abbreviated to mod
arg form and if someone is exceptionally
lazy like i was when i was giving you
the title today
and i like this because it sort of
refers to what's going on
like in a visual way um because this is
all based on
a poll namely the origin the name that i
prefer
and it's the laziest one is polar form
okay but they all mean
the same thing so how do we convert back
and forth
between these converting x plus y
and r cos theta sine theta
going to give you example so if we
had a complex number like i actually
picked one specifically for this where
is my complex number
oh there it is root 3
plus i here is a complex number
it's in standard cartesian rectangular
form you can see the real part
and the imaginary oh by the way sorry
this is a bit awkward but there is one
more name for this one which i forgot
which is
a bit weird it's called real imaginary
form
i find this name strange because like
well that's what a complex number is but
i'm just saying it because you will see
it and someone's going to ask me a
question so there you go
how do we take this form which separates
the real and imaginary
into this form we need to think about
all the things that we just set up over
here for starters
we want to begin with our modulus how do
we find that
r equals we already stated it right
fantastic square root of and then you're
going to have the squares of your real
and imaginary components so in this case
you'll have
negative root 3 squared that's the real
part
what's the imaginary part it's 1 plus 1
squared
is that all right if you get teachers
who are giving you nice numbers you will
see that this ends up with something
friendly this is the square root of 3
plus 1 of course
so we're going to get the square root of
4 which is 2. great
so we have a modulus now from here
i'm going to take those two equations
the x1 and the y1
and i'm going to use the r value which
i've just found
and i'm going to solve for theta so i
can say
think about this if x equals r cos
theta therefore
have a look have a look closely you've
got all the information you need
the x coordinate is negative root 3
yes the r that we just determined was 2
and then i've got cos theta is that all
right tidied up a teeny amount
cos theta equals negative root 3 on
2. okay now this of course is not enough
information
to work out specifically which angle
theta is so i'm going to go to the other
equation over there which is in y y
is equal to r
sine theta very good in this case
my y coordinate like you guys told me
when we work out the modulus is
1 and i already worked out what r was
it's 2
so i've got sine theta equals
a half so you can see we've given you
nice numbers that are corresponding to
exact values do you see that and you'll
see that come up
a lot not all the time but frequently
okay
all right now what we can do here is we
can say on the complex plane
putting these two together allows me to
unambiguously work out
what theta should be for example i
wonder how many of you know by the way
we're in radians and we're going to come
back later on to why it's so important
we're in radians and not degrees
has anyone is anyone comfortable enough
with radians to know off the bat what
are our two exact values in our normal
domain that we think about the fit with
this
any takers i'll give you a clue the
first one starts with
pi pi on what
pi on six very good right pi on six is
my first solution that goes with this
i'm just going to jot it down so it's
not in my brain
what's the other one in that normal
domain
it's going to be 5 3 5
think carefully it's going to be 5
pi on six as well right now just just to
know i should pause here
as you can see even though we're dealing
just with like arithmetic before right
we have very quickly moved into
trigonometry land
and just a heads up it ain't going away
now i know you haven't spent much time
on that
recently if this is something where
you're like i can't
i can't think of these angles like
immediately you can see this is not the
focus of the question
like this is the focus of the question
so maybe trigonometry is something which
you're getting a signal now i need to go
back and revise it will be super helpful
for you just like times tables are
when you're dealing with fractions
you're like oh i got to find common
denominators i do not want to be
thinking hard about like the multiples
of three or four or five
i want to be able to do this and do it
like that that makes sense
later on we'll come to it how do i
determine between
each of these which one fits well i'm
going to use this
other trig ratio here right if you
wanted if you wanted to draw like a
quadrance diagram like so
right from this and i just started with
this because it was positive so we
generally know it better
um which quadrants were i was i in pi on
6 and 5.6
are the first and second right because
of course
sine is positive so you're in these two
quadrants yes
but from the other trig ratio cos theta
is
this it's negative so that gives you
more information which
which quadrants do you have to be in if
cos is negative
second and third right so you're now
over here but you can see because it's
the same
theta right it's the same theta it can't
be in in either of these it has to fit
into here does that make sense second
quadrant
there was another way by the way a
sneaky way you could have known that
before you even wrote down any trig how
do we know we're in the second quadrant
have a thing what are you saying
go back to the fact that this is written
in cartesian form right it's
negative root 3 that's that way
plus i that's that way so that's another
confirmation for you
you're in the second quadrant makes
sense you can see from here
by the way you're going to get another
pair of answers but clearly this is the
one
that you're going to be interested in so
therefore wrong color i can say
uh i'm going to write it down just
because we were doing that reasoning
over there quadrant two
and the way i got that was from number
one rectangular form but number two
also from the fact that sine theta is
positive and
cos theta is negative so that also tells
you you're in the second quadrant
theta equals 5 pi on
6. is that okay now let's think about
this it's always really good to do a
sense check right i now have a value for
r
and a value for theta so would it make
sense to say
z equals two bracket i'm now just
reciting uh mod arg form polar form now
cos of five pi on six plus
i sine 5 pi on
6. does that make sense
let's draw this thing up
i don't know why i drew so much on the
bottom negative
root 3 whoops negative root 3 plus
i i want to get a decent sensor scale on
this just to see if this is reasonable
or not
so if i go negative 1 negative 2 does
anyone know what root 3 roughly is
one point seven ish that's all i need
because i'm only doing a rough sketch so
i'm gonna place it about there
this is negative root three plus i am
going to go at one unit so i'm gonna try
and keep to scale so that i have
something that i can go off here that's
reliable
so if there's if that's i right there
then here is where z should be
does this seem to make sense of the
angle
and the modulus the argument and modulus
i should say that looks like five pounds
six to me
and also noting that this distance has
to be one
then this distance has to be 1.7 then
that hypotenuse there does make sense to
be two because it has to be longer than
both of those
make sense cool so here's what i'd like
you to do
i'm going to pause there there is
obviously way more to explore in polar
form but this is the beginning
on canvas you'll see exercise one day is
linked and in the calendar the
particular questions are there
for those of you whose brains are
ticking over i really want you to go
back to this
conundrum i posed to you of why did i go
through cause and sign
why didn't i just go through tan if you
really want to have a think about that
then um
if you come up with an answer let mr
liesel i know we'd love to hear your
theories okay